welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you're now
locked into the channel where we've been
watching The Watchmen to break down
everything that you need to know about
the new season throughout this video
we'll be recapping the second entry in
the series thus far and discussing where
the show could be heading in the future
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch
episode 2 yet and don't want to know
what happens then I highly suggest that
you turn off now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of Watchmen episode - okay
so episode 1 saw a city under siege with
the rise of the 7th cavalry a group of
white supremacists that were looking to
bring chaos into the streets in the name
of Rorschach whilst the masked vigilante
was never like that in the comic books
they have twisted his message and it's
up to the police to bring an end to this
threat we joined cisternae and the
police department as they slowly worked
to take down the rogue organization and
just when it seemed like the police were
beginning to make headway in the war the
police captain was mysteriously murdered
by an unknown assassin that sent a
powerful message tonight similar to the
prior entry episode 2 has an
introduction that is very much steeped
in real-world history and we open on a
German commandant dictating a leaflet
that will be sent out to
african-american soldiers to try and
convince them to surrender to the German
army in the promise of a better life
history dictates to us that Germany
actually used to forcibly sterilized
black citizens living in Germany and
this plain lie told by the German forces
in the opening reminds us just how
tactical that they were as an army they
attempted to dissuade many of the
soldiers by reminding them of white
America is very much anti black mindset
at the time and we followed the black
father from the beginning of the prior
episode who grabs one of these notes as
they are being hair dropped though he
turns down the Germans offer he takes
the pamphlet home and returns to
Oklahoma where his son who we left in
the opener of the last episode discovers
them we did theorize last time that this
would be revealed to be the elderly man
in the wheelchair that knew of Angela's
of the ego and episode 2 confirms this
all while it's filling in who he really
is and how he knows so much flash
forward to the present
and with Judds body still swinging from
a tree Angela takes the man to her quote
unquote bakery teller off some steam
make him a cup of coffee and get to the
bottom of what happened we learn that
the character is called will and that he
is a one hundred five year old psychic
who killed Jud last episode he asked
Angela if she thought that he could lift
200 pounds and we learn this episode
that this is because he was the one who
killed captain and strung him up he says
that he did this with his mind which he
can use to manipulate things and because
Jude had skeletons in his closet he says
that there is a big conspiracy in the
area but if he divulges everything then
it will make Angela's head explode
Angela and I'm guessing all of the
audience at this point don't believe
this as he comes out with some
inconsistencies and she leaves at
returning to the site of the captain's
body which is now turned into a crime
scene along the way we pass a newsstand
that is very similar to the one in the
original comic book at which the young
boy read the tales of the black
freighter was the news vendor spouted
things off there's also a copy of the
new frontiersman and a mention of the
Nova Express which many will remember
from the original graphic novel as some
of the many publications in it
it states that global squid Falls baffle
scientists and this is in reference to
the giant alien from the end of the
graphic novel as well as the weather
conditions that we noticed in the last
episode at the crime scene Angela meets
with Looking Glass who seems to have
in-depth knowledge of everything that's
happened to the captain during his final
few minutes I'm telling you this guy is
an inside mole and he seems very suspect
towards Angela and she says that he's
cold which she rebuffs with well why am
i crying under here we can clearly see
that he's not crying and I'm getting my
tinfoil hat out because I'm sure this
guy is up to something
when Angela mentions her kids he also
questions it and as we know she is a
foster mother so this is a little close
to the bone for me at least and shows
that he knows a great deal about the
character even though he isn't letting
on we are reminded of why Angela hasn't
got any kids as well in a flashback that
shows firsthand the elements that were
paid lip-service to in the last episode
we go to Christmas Eve with attention
drawn directly to the clock and see
Angela and Cal as they are accosted by
members of the cavalry that break in and
begin shooting and the characters it's
an awesome action scene that really show
is just how much this show has the
standoffs nailed and watching the
violins play out to the song Santa baby
reminded me of the opening of The
Watchmen movie in which our boy Ozzie
fought the comedian to unforgettable
Angela looks like she's about to die but
she awakens in hospital to find Judd
sitting beside her he informs her that
40 police officers houses were hit in
the cavalry attack and we learned that
Angela's kids are actually the children
of her partner and his wife who were
killed during the night and that she
adopted them after the event due to the
attacks the remaining police force
members have resigned and the two remain
defiant joined together and forming a
strong bond through it now this is where
you start to get the idea that Jude may
have been in on the attacks and then
this could be what we'll was referring
to as the conspiracy earlier in the
episode after the death of their chief
the police decide that now is the
perfect time for a counter-attack and
they raid the motor homes from the first
episode in order to do a roundup that
will weed out the cavalry members it's
over the top a bloody and full of
awesome moments that really hint at the
conflict that we are slowly building
towards between the two sides
we know that the police have the power
to beat these guys into a bloody pulp
but they aren't playing by the rules a
nurse even with the extra authority
Angela and Co are pretty much
defenseless against the guerrilla
tactics that they are able to use
without the way Angela heads to the
Greenwood Center which is a memorial
area for those that died during the
real-world attack in the opening of
Episode one it's a place that allows for
you to test if you deserve reparations
through submitting DNA and due to the
president Robert Redford being in power
these are known as red for Asians they
haven't gone down well with the public
and we very much get the subtext that
these things are slowly dividing the
community and they are a main point of
conflict Angela uses wills DNA which she
took from his coffee cup to see if he
was really at the scene now it also
looks like there may be someone watching
Angela though this could be an innocent
bystander they just seemed so much in
the frame I start to suspect something
was up anyway let me know if you agree
with that or if you think it's just some
stranger which yet it might just be back
home Angela runs into what I believe is
her adopted kids grandfather who wishes
to visit them though Angela stops this
we also get a minor look at the
show-within-a-show that is the American
hero story similar to the original
graphic novel
had a comic with in a comic this follows
Ralf Muller who faked his own death and
is revealed to be hooded justice a
vigilante from the graphic novel that
was part of the Minutemen though it's
believed in the book that he was
murdered by Ralph Miller we actually
learn that they are one of the same this
clears up a big conspiracy theory that
Watchmen fans have had for decades and
I'm glad that through the show we are
getting some answers in regards to the
source material back in the Watchmen
world angela travels to geodes wake
under the guise of grieving for the
character he or she meets Senator Joe
Keene who I believe may be the son of
Senator John Keene from the graphic
novel he was the senator that passed the
law known as the Keene act that outlawed
vigilantes and made the Watchmen go into
hiding angela feigns passing out in
order to be taken upstairs and wakes up
in judge room where after his wife
leaves allows her to put on x-ray
goggles in order to investigate his
personal life now here we get another
big twist in Judds life with the reveal
that he was indeed a member of the
cavalry and it's one of the most
mind-blowing twists in watchmen history
showcasing that she really contrasts any
one the twists don't stop there though
and I'll get into another big one in
just a bit cut to Ozymandias is castle
and we discover that his servants are
actually clones and not androids like I
thought last time together they are
putting together the production of the
watch makers Sun which will portray the
origin story of dr. Manhattan those
who've seen the film adaptation will
remember this as one of the seminal
moments and it's great watching Ozzie
over the moon with a stage school level
production of it he ends up killing the
clone cuz a he can always make a new one
and the heir hilarious moments here with
a bit of blue dick in it as well
we finally got it back to the bakery
Angela finds well cooking eggs after
somehow escaping and she begins accusing
him of setting up jerd though we know
deep down that this isn't true it's
revealed through the DNA sample that
will is in fact Angela's grandfather and
there is also another relative of the
two out there somewhere we don't get
confirmation on who this is but I don't
believe that they've been introduced
into the show yet Angela doesn't want to
hear this though and arrests him putting
him in a car before he is miraculously
rescued by a crap that flies overhead
and escorts him away with a magnet this
confirms that he indeed does have
friends in high places and mirroring the
start of the episode
will drops a flyer out of the air which
Angela catches it says watch over this
boy which leaves her questioning exactly
what's happened now the ending of the
episode may leave you scratching your
head but personally I believe that this
is the original a night owl Archy ship
and that it has been commandeered by
Aussies since the retirement of Dan who
is now setting up the pieces to create a
race war in Tulsa to end the conflict
similar to how he did in the original
graphic novel going forward I believe
that he is setting the pieces in place
and needs will out the picture due to
his ability to inform Angela of exactly
what's happening and in the next episode
we will follow Ozzy's plan as it begins
to hem Phil it looks like the 7th
cavalry attacks are beginning to
increase unless the government is
attempting to contact dr. Manhattan in
order to come back to earth and
intervene in the conflict either way
there are lots of things that could
potentially happen and no doubt there
will be a wealth of theories over where
the show is heading it definitely has
been gripped and a massively preferred
this entry over the prior one with this
episode having me engaged throughout now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode as well as what you took
from its ending comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my breakdown of last
week's episode which would be linked at
the end I'm gonna be going through the
series episode by episode so it's
definitely worth staying locked to the
channel if you want to know more also in
the podcast called watching The Watchmen
in which we break down the graphic novel
so make sure you give that a watch if
you're a fan of the source material you
want to come chat to me after the video
then please follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which you'll be linked in
the description below those the best
ways to stay up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully I see over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the Marvel phase 3 part 1 box a blu-ray
which contains Civil War Doctor Strange
homecoming Ragnarok and more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on Watchmen in the comment
section below but one is gonna be chosen
on the 15th of November and the set will
be shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]